all right thanks john now to our
carnival's coverage
vaccines are now available this morning
for seniors here in southern nevada
the health district announced those over
70 can now make appointments bianca
coleman live near the mega vaccination
site with how you can get an appointment
good morning bianca
a lot of people wondering how this works
hey
yes good morning alex so for months
cashman center has actually been a
testing site but now it's going to be a
vaccination site
and so thousands will be able to get the
vaccine here the health district they
recently released a vaccination plan
folks 70 and older will start getting
the vaccine in a few days as of
wednesday the health district has
administered 29 000 doses of the vaccine
the goal is to get to 40 to 45 000 in a
week
moving forward our senior population
60 to 80 is the highest capacity
in the hospitals so it's very important
we have that track
the health district is working on more
locations such as the las vegas
convention center
and the state is also working on a plan
with major pharmacy companies
which will help increase sites as well
throughout the valley in various
neighborhoods
and we want to stress the importance of
having an appointment you can't just
show up here and get a shot you must go
online to their website
to make an appointment first and again
you must be 70 or older and of course
frontline workers are also are going to
be able to get vaccines here as well
we've got all this information
on our website at 8newsnow.com reporting
live from cashman center bianca holman 8
news now